françois patriat vous avez manifesté ce
que vous pensiez du front national il ya
quelques jours en disant voter front
national c'est voter des ch vous avez le
sentiment de pas avoir été entendu ce
soir donc ce qu'on peut dire aujourd'hui
parce que à cette heure ci on sait une
chose
conformément aux sondages on est à peu
près dans dans les cales qui était prévu
avec un front national qu'elle qu'il est
estimée une gauche plus haut qu'elle
n'était prévue et une droite
républicaine plus bas qu'il n'était
prévu
si on veut tirer des conclusions pour
l'issue du scrutin
ce qu'on sait c'est que ça va se jouer à
un ou deux points on regarde les
réserves quant à la gauche elle en est
certaine les réserves car la droite
on a aussi et la marge cas le fn de
pouvoir progresser parce qu'il a
progressé dans les derniers scrutins
mais tout ça va se jouer à deux points
donc tiré ce soir des conclusions
définitives n'a aucun sens
ensuite la surcroît de nouveaux temps
acquis at il profité
il a profité bien entendu au fn il ya eu
plus de votants et ouvert qui sont allés
sur le fn il a profité aussi à la gauche
et malheureusement malheureusement pour
la peau les républicains il a
aujourd'hui pas profité à eux c'est eux
qui sont les premiers perdants sur les
premiers perdants et chacun doit retirer
ce soir les conclusions
ce qui veut dire qu'avec les sondages
tels qu'ils sont donnés aujourd'hui il
ya encore deux part d'inconnu première
pour nous est pas inconnu
c est ce que le front de gauche va faire
cinq ou vingt cinq donc est ce qu'ils
seront mobilisés pour le deuxième tour
est ce que cette destination au
vainqueur
est ce que l'europe europe ecologie les
verts vont faire 5 se maintenir aussi sa
salle le comte on aura les résultats
définitifs ce qu'on dit à cette heure ne
sera peut-être pas ce qu'on dira à 23
mai pour la droite ce sujet debout la
france à ses sujets alentours de la
barrière des 5
ce qui est important tout de même voie
deux bouts la france il m'apparaît que
ce sont des électeurs qui ne sont pas
séduits par la droite républicaine
classique et qui ne et qui n'ont pas
voulu voter front national
alors qu'elle sera au deuxième tour leur
vote on ne sait pas même sur une
mobilisation supplémentaire
ce que je souhaite c'est que face au
danger que représente le front national
je vais répondre à votre question la
mobilisation soit forte pour les partis
républicains notamment pour le parti
auquel j'appartiens
pour répondre à votre question sur neige
ce que j'ai dit n'était pas seul à le
dire d'autres l'ont dit compris at on
attend christian 10,3 il ce que je dis
aujourd'hui c'est que à mon avis des
chouettes le cas au deich souhaite le
cas où il soit le quart de notre pays et
il souhaite avoir un gouvernement
des gens qui soient radicalement à
droite pour radier pour radicaliser les
populations qui sont venus d'orient ou
d'ailleurs et par là même à voir dans
notre pays une montée de l'islamisme
c'est ce qu'il souhaite aujourd'hui ils
le disent ils l'écrivent et moi c'est
moi c'est ma crainte à moi je les dis un
peu violemment
je les dis aussi autrement dit l'autre
jour j'ai dit que aujourd'hui même
meilleur agent électoral pour le fn
s'était d'ailleurs je répète ici
ce qu'a dit marion maréchal-le pen elle
a dit avec un cynisme inouï
avec un cynisme inouï il est vrai que
les attentats en booster notre campagne
voilà dynamiser notre campagne
donc je retire parce que j'ai dit
c'était certes un peu caricatural je
vous le dis mais ça reflète au fond une
idée que je crois certaines de voir que
les partis extrémistes
montrons si jamais le front national
arrivé au pouvoir merci françois patriat
sur la discussion avec vous